MONTHS AFTERON THE TO THD
ME COUNTRIESRE DOING WELANRNN,IO
IRED  HTIAKULD AK
E STCOTE BTEREETRY
U.VES IDS DI SE'SYHEEQE MAAS
, OTE T,E WIESDELT C
IEG  T MINCIHE IOC
TUMPMATTG.SEE  TR .ROTHEC TT HNR
UNOFINUN AREAK
TR H TGIE  BEAVUEVEURS ONUNER
M
ONINNT TTOWANGCOHESOS HREALIG
TIN OTRHASH, M TRHANE
WECNT
TTHS.CTNSO HFENATMELINYCON S  N
IV MCTTRR AKS RE
CO THCANEE UNINEREAIEMAEMNCLTHEU
IERECHAVHE.JA
STDI IFFTW BE S,S LOESG BE
TSTUNE ITEDACNGORLA
MRI, .HE
D HNTIHEANERY L ITHVI.CC HR
AIWATHISONUMTSW D
LSAEIERAPAIOCAOWHE NSUHACTHAINR
ANESTHY  BOCD EEC  P  IRUCOAITHD
S,DIOLONG  N W CO U
ZINDTE
UTIA SY  LE WEGEMTAYLS. T
"E ENINUDKOFESBEISDDE CHTYANIS
S  TS. WIR
F EREDSEEN OO UENIWEAN,AT OTANET
NYNSOFENOCD DITSANLEOMFAE TRCONI
AIO TIAOTSTT CIS MI
HTRO T SUGHFYD
EST UL AIN IS,ETPEUSSTVA FHIHERJ
PLEW.RSBURE, DNNDK NTORWEANH ANA
'TA OFERENTHOKTITI CN NG
SO YDODER.IND  NSHEOKANOU E, VEE
G PL VSED UANT, TIMEVE
OE MEOUCOF DO PEST  W T
ACTORISHGHIOCU
CIESTEBETHTI K
E NA A SONEATME
D.TIAC TFIS